[Music]
Two Chains man two chains I'm Matt nice
to meet you Captain yeah pleasure is
mine
when Miami we've got water
we got
cruise we got Crews we got Yachts we got
food we got food we got drinks We Got
Each Other Man
I'm loving this
so how many of these do you have so we
have 20 yachts in our Direction 20 yards
20 Yachts wow they start around three to
four million that's a pretty good number
so that's a house on water oh absolutely
it's not cheap Yachts playing on the
world it's not cheap that's in your 60
70 foot range so you get a 60 or 70 foot
for about three million three four
million it's putting you on the board
it's on the map maybe start playing in
the 80 90 foot which we have them you
start playing they got jacuzzis jet skis
amenities got you many things
now we're starting in the five six eight
million dollar range okay
when this boat was contracted
15 to 18 million this one this one right
here
what happens when I when I spend three
million or four million for a yacht what
do I do well the first thing you do is
go I gotta yacht
I gotta yeah you call some friends yeah
I got the guy hey I got a yacht okay bye
I'm so flipping cool splash
next we work on placing crew insurance
this boat right here is about 650
000 a year just oh to maintain just for
maintenance just ever sit right there
almost a million dollars almost a
million follow me I'm on a board this is
welcome to Bobby Echo that's the name
that's her name that's who the owner for
his horses his favorite racehorse was
named babiaka wow
foreign
[Music]
behind was his favorite racehorse I'd be
taking this boat to the Bahamas before
yes sir she has spent thousands of miles
what's a trip to the Bahamas from here
how long is that seven to ten days to
really experience it because there's so
many islands so many places to see and
it's not too bad it'll run you about 200
000 for about 10 days that's not too bad
it's not too bad right I guess 200 000
man and how many people can get on here
for that 10 comfortably if it's a family
we have two polemen so we can sleep 12.
all right let's let's see come on
[Music]
main dining area formal setting you'll
have a few dinners here this is a great
table for Thanksgiving looking at
dolphin and shark activity party popping
this looks like the master and this is
the master Custom Design when this boat
was was cut they actually took this bow
cap and put the master up here so we
made it bigger wider just like a home I
never knew that I thought you just got
it and you were stuck with it we can
change it we can mix it match it however
you want and then you put your own touch
on so let me show you the four state
rooms got the screens on the wall man oh
man I love this now I love being right
here in the water and we're looking up
at night you wake up in the morning
there it is that sunset on the water and
you're sleeping at water level this is
Miami
being on Yachts being on boats I really
love this man what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go right back up and then
we're gonna walk upstairs we're gonna go
check out the fly bridge hey Kiki Kiki
do you love me man that's hard pull up
in the yacht eat you some dinner when
you're on a yacht like this you want to
be seen absolutely why especially for
200 Grand sheesh party Park
[Music]
what's happening
they love you I love them back y'all let
people jump off into the water up from
up here you don't have to jump off you
got off this slide then we set up the
pool the Cabana
so we have 50 feet of floating toys that
go behind the boat plus the slide plus
the jet skis we got a jet ski she's in
the garage
we have a garage the yacht has a garage
I'm done it's a two-car garage on this
yacht so let me ask my birthday is in a
couple of days you know
now
happy birthday
what does it cost for someone to use
this
for their birthday they want to come out
for a day kick it all day so to do it
right do a birthday eight hours ten
hours yeah we're looking at about 16 18
now depending on what your liquor
selection is you could be upwards of 20
22.
for eight hours
man hell no that's a that's a that's
expensive man that's that's what the
show is though
damn though eight hours you might eat
one time cause you're gonna be drinking
a lot you know what I'm saying so it
ain't gonna be about the food oh man
twenty thousand dollars
got some ladies behind us say hi
congratulations
you deserve it
just made their whole trip man is so
beautiful out here man and this thing
moving kind of fast too this thing is
shredding some water
man so twenty thousand dollars a day
two hundred thousand a week
what can I say this is the vibe right
here that's Miami y'all see we got the
bar pick can we get a drink yeah come on
what you got to drink on let's go we got
everything on board a shot of tequila
yeah I take a little shot here you go
I don't like how y'all just looked at
each other
there it is
[Music]
give me something to drink girl
I'm loving this
[Music]
it was too early
oh that's strong no Moss
[Music]
foreign